[Música]
el 52.6 por ciento de la población en
honduras del sexo femenino por lo cual
el papel de nosotras como mujeres es
fundamental en esta sociedad de hecho
que la participación de las mujeres en
honduras se ha incrementado y está
haciendo cada vez más relevante tanto en
el ámbito de liderazgo como en el
mercado laboral muchas de nuestras
mujeres están siendo protagonistas en
uno de los principales rubros de
exportación de nuestro país nos
referimos
para la industria maquiladora con una
presencia del 55 por ciento
estamos brillando mujeres
[Música]
gracias al crecimiento que ha tenido la
industria en nuestro país muchas de
nuestras mujeres han logrado penetrar al
mundo laboral y de esta forma generar
ingresos económicos para su familia sin
embargo la realidad que ellas
experimentan a diario no es del todo
favorable es decir no tienen acceso a
mejorar su calidad de vida integral
pese a que poseen una oportunidad
laboral
por ejemplo muchas de las mujeres que
laboran en las fábricas tienen niveles
educativos bajos
son menores de 30 años y madres solteras
que les toca asumir el papel de jefas de
hogar sumando a esta dura realidad
muchas de esas mujeres experimentan
problemas personales familiares y
sociales como por ejemplo tienen baja
autoestima sufren de estrés ansiedad
depresión sufren violencia doméstica en
sus hogares que están endeudadas y si
nos referimos a sus condiciones
laborales encontraremos que los salarios
que ganan las operarias son de los
rangos más bajos
además están expuestas a extensas
jornadas laborales y no sólo eso a
tareas que involucran movimientos
repetitivos los cuales podrían
desencadenar problemas de salud en un
futuro
en el año 2009 se realizó un estudio en
honduras sobre las condiciones de
trabajo salud y estrés en las mujeres
que laboran en las fábricas y saben que
se encontró algo muy preocupante un
nivel de estrés alto en estas mujeres a
un nivel de 84% y no sólo eso se
encontraron en ellas enfermedades
irritativas trastornos mentales y
psicosomáticos la mayoría de estas
enfermedades estaban asociadas con el
estrés
y todas esas problemáticas y no sólo la
viven las mujeres de las fábricas
todos nosotros podemos estar expuestas y
expuestos a distintas de estas
problemáticas
cuál es el mayor desafío
el mayor desafío ante todo esto es que
las mujeres no se sienten valoradas
mucho menos se sienten empoderados para
actuar carecen de orientación para poder
enfrentar sus problemáticas
[Música]
conocen ustedes mujeres que laboran en
fábricas
sí
de percepción han tenido de ellas
tienen idea de las historias que viven
[Música]
trabajando de lleno con mujeres en las
fábricas pudimos conocer esa realidad
muy de cerca les contaré cuatro casos
trinidad
trinidad había estado luchando con un
contexto de violencia por un periodo de
más de diez años imágenes no podía
expresarse ante su propio cónyuge porque
la maltrataba física y psicológicamente
número 2 en línea
lilian había estado teniendo ideas
suicidas a causa de los problemas que
tenía con sus hijos
número 3 leonel a leonela había tenido
tantos problemas familiares que fue
incapacitada en su trabajo debido a la
depresión
y dulce a pesar de ser una mujer con un
liderazgo nato no podía alcanzar sus
metas porque tenía muchos problemas
financieros sino así que no podía
alcanzar sus sueños
la gran pregunta es cómo podemos
ayudarles
a ella sí a muchas como ellas a
encontrar su voz
hay buenas noticias
en el año 2012 la fundación walmart
lanzó el proyecto a mujeres en las
fábricas
una iniciativa mundial de formación para
formar a 60 mil mujeres en 150 fábricas
en 5 países y lo mejor de todo honduras
nuestro país es uno de ellos
eso es maravilloso en este país este
proyecto fue ejecutado por la
organización war vision
el proyecto consistió en un programa de
entrenamiento que se desarrolló en
cuatro etapas principales como pueden
ver la primera etapa era la formación
gerencial a todos los gerentes de las
fábricas la segunda etapa la formación
básica dirigida a hombres y mujeres
dentro de las fábricas la tercera etapa
la formación avanzada dirigida
específicamente para mujeres y la cuarta
etapa la formación de formadoras donde
se preparaba a todas estas mujeres para
que pudieran ser mujeres líderes y
pudieran luego replicar el programa
toda esta formación les proveyó un
espacio les dio herramientas necesarias
para poder encontrar su voz
con la metodología constructivista y con
el lema de aprender jugando
estas mujeres pudieron desarrollarse en
tres áreas principales
primera el ámbito personal porque el
ámbito personal porque el ámbito
personal es el primer paso para el
empoderamiento
debido a que cuando las mujeres
descubren quiénes son se llaman a sí
mismas y confían en sus propias
capacidades podemos decir que ha
iniciado el proceso de empoderamiento
segunda área un segundo ámbito ámbito
social porque en el ámbito social porque
para el empoderamiento es necesario
desarrollar habilidades de negociación
primeramente comenzando con los más
cercanos como ser los miembros de su
familia para luego poder extenderse más
allá hacia comunidades o hacia
organizaciones y la 'número tres' el
ámbito laboral porque el ámbito laboral
porque para el empoderamiento se
requiere que nosotros le brindemos a las
mujeres espacios de participación donde
ellas también se han tomado horas de
decisiones y también de esa forma se
pueda superar la desigualdad de género
que hay en nuestro país
para desarrollarlas en estas tres áreas
se impartieron diferentes temáticas y en
cada una de las temáticas las mujeres
fueron cambiando les voy a contar un
poco con el tema de comunicación las
mujeres perdieron el miedo a hablar en
frente hablar frente a una persona y
expresar sus ideas con el de autoestima
las mujeres descubrieron quiénes son y
aprendieron su valor como mujeres únicas
con género comenzaron a practicar
comportamientos y actitudes diferentes
de equidad como por ejemplo en la
crianza de sus hijos en su familia en su
trabajo y lo más importante no permitir
nunca más ni que las humillar ni la
violencia de género
en salud integral las mujeres
adquirieron nuevos hábitos de salud se
alimentaban mejor ahora estaban
pendientes de la prevención de
enfermedades de transmisión sexual
estaban pendientes de sus exámenes
regulares de prevención como ser la
citología y el autoexamen de mamas
en resolución de conflictos las mujeres
lograron resolver sus desafíos
utilizando la guía para solución de
conflictos en alfabetismo funcional las
mujeres desarrollaron habilidades tanto
de lectura como de escritura no sólo eso
se motivaron a la preparación académica
muchas de ellas a través de ese
entrenamiento decidieron ingresar al
colegio y otra decidieron terminar sus
estudios
con el módulo de finanzas las mujeres se
pusieron a hacer sus presupuestos
familiares adquirieron conciencia del
consumismo emprendieron planes de ahorro
y hasta actividades de emprendimiento en
sus familias
y con el módulo de liderazgo
desarrollaron habilidades personales
como trabajo en equipo motivación
inteligencia emocional y cómo expresarse
ante la gente
ahí lo vemos
todo lo que se ha logrado en ellos
estas mujeres lograron encontrar su voz
pudimos ayudarles en tres áreas
específicas primero cambiando el clima
laboral de sus fábricas y segundo
trayendo un mejor bienestar a su familia
dado que ahora las familias practican
hábitos más saludables tienen cultura de
ahorro y hasta de emprendimiento
y lo más importante le dimos un espacio
para que su voz fuese escuchada
como les dimos este espacio porque
muchas de ellas ahora son líderes
internas que replican el programa en sus
propias fábricas y ayudan a otras
mujeres y otras tienen grupos de apoyo
fuera de sus fábricas para que puedan
ellas contar sus experiencias con las
mujeres de su comunidad esto es
maravilloso de verdad
y qué pasó se acuerdan de nuestras
queridas
trinidad william dulce qué pasó con ella
después de los entrenamientos
trinidad logró ser asertiva expresarse
ante su cónyuge y nunca más permitir que
lo mirarán fue tanto el cambio de
trinidad que en un evento de grabación
del programa ella se paró frente a todos
y con todo su testimonio había perdido
totalmente el temor y han decidido
enfocarse en sus hijos
lilian escribió al finalizar el programa
no sé qué hubiese pasado conmigo quizás
hubiese estado muerta pero ahora
entiendo que mis hijos me aman y en esta
enfocándose en ellos
leonela logró superar la depresión y no
sólo eso ahora está ayudando a más
mujeres en su fábrica ya que es parte
del grupo de mujeres entrenadores
y dulce logro cumplir sus sueños claro
que sí dulce se propuso junto con su
esposo montar un plan de ahorro para
poder tener a su hijo en una escuela
bilingüe ya que era uno de sus sueños y
lo logró
dulce también tuvo la genial idea de
crear una cooperativa en su iglesia
no sólo eso también es emprendedora
montó un negocio de horchata sí ahora
famosa con ellas
y aún hay más aún enfoco todo su
liderazgo para poder ayudar mujeres de
su comunidad siendo parte ahora del
grupo de mujeres líderes que replican el
programa en sus fábricas
en honduras treinta y cinco fábricas
participaron de esta iniciativa 637
gerente dijeron sí al programa en la
primera etapa se capacitarán a 11 mil
600 personas en la segunda etapa se
capacitarán a novecientos setenta
mujeres líderes y en la última etapa se
prepararon a 220 que ahora están
entrenadas para poder replicar el
programa
y es maravilloso ver lo que puede
suceder cuando las mujeres encuentran su
voz
ahora en honduras existe una gran
comunidad de mujeres que necesitan ayuda
empoderándose organizaciones empresa
privada gobierno ciudadanos todos
nosotros necesitamos involucrarnos a
ayudar a escuchar la voz de las mujeres
de las niñas de honduras y de todo el
mundo mi sueño es poder ver las futuras
generaciones de mujeres empoderadas
amándose a sí mismas tomando nuevos
retos y siendo líderes sin temor a ser
criticadas
les comparto una frase de melinda gates
que me ha inspirado mucho para poder
seguir trabajando en el empoderamiento
de la mujer
[Música]
una mujer como una voz es por definición
una mujer poderosa pero la búsqueda para
encontrar esa voz puede ser
extremadamente difícil
ayudémosles
[Aplausos]